I actually don't care about anything else.
Speed both in people skills and hard work will trump anything.
("99" by Russ ft. Totem &amp; Paulina)
(heart monitor beeping)
Speed is four billion times more important than perfection.
Speed.
When you're not spending any time worrying,
your spending time on executing.
That's what a great culture is.
It's speed.
You're not spending the 15 minutes a day bickering.
You're not spending the four hours a day wondering if that
person trying to ruin you.
I understand it's a race and yet speed is a variable for success
to me in a big way.
Hustle, patience and speed are very much rubbing against each
other but it's like the diamond comes from that.
On your day-to-day work,
you have to be fast with the clients.
They email you, you email them back.
Like your day-to-day but your vision,
what you want to achieve in life you're not gonna build it in
one year and so many people have it reversed.
In the day-to-day they're slow and in the macro they want their
business to be huge the next day.
People talk a big game.
"GaryVee, you're gonna buy the Jets,
"I'm gonna buy the Rams."
Yo, bro, nobody, nobody unless they were a trust fund baby ever
bought the Rams when they go skiing
for a week when they're 24.
I am massively, at a global level patient but on a
practical level and an execution level, I'm very fast.
It really is religion and church.
When you align on religion you can go fast and speed is such a
bigger aspect of business than people realize and so instead of
jockeying and politicking and pondering and posturing and
debating for three or four months,
we're just in do mode now
and when you're in do mode
you fucking get shit done.
So I just went on a huge email storm I guess,
email rant to the whole company.
It was great.
It was huge communication thing about the inefficiencies.
I just got a lot done in an hour and a half on email that will
impact our company for a long time.
I think it's crazy when Goliath loses to David.
Goliath should never lose to David.
That means bad strategy.
If we're David 'cause it's us versus WPP,
get a fucking rock and put it in his fucking eye.
If you don't give a fuck about what people think,
you can do everything.
The reality is I think speed trumps so much
that I'm blown away by people that get caught up in this
and really it just leads to you being
disproportionately not successful
because you're too slow.
You're overthinking things.
Speed is the only thing that matters,
and opinions predicated on people's insecurities and ego
slows shit down.
("99" by Russ ft. Totem &amp; Paulina)